in this video you're going to learn how
to write the standard form of the
equation of a circle and we're going to
talk about a couple of different
examples where you have the center point
and then a point on the circle and you
want to write that equation of the
circle in standard form but before we
get to those examples
let's talk about where does the standard
form of the equation of a circle come
from well say you have the center of a
circle right here this point and it's h
comma K those are the coordinates and
then you have a point on the circle
let's call that point p and that's going
to be the coordinates X and Y and we
know the distance from the center of the
circle to any point on the circle is the
radius so what a circle is it's the set
of points
okay so you have all these points here
that are equidists from equidistant from
a given point called the center point
and that distance is the radius R so
going back to Algebra 1 remember you
learned the distance formula it's the
square root of the difference in the x
coordinates squared plus the difference
in the Y coordinates squared you add
those two quantities together and you
take the square root and that gives you
the distance so in this case if we use
these two points and we find the
distance we're going to say X2 minus X1
so in this case it would be x minus h
squared and then Y2 minus y1 so that's
going to be y minus K quantity squared
add those together and take the square
root and that's our distance but in this
case you can see that the distance
represents the radius now all we have to
do now is square both sides so that the
square and the square root those are
inverses they cancel one another out and
we're left with
this form
which is our standard form of the
equation of a circle the only difference
is I flipped it and that's how we're
getting this equation right here keep in
mind that the center of the circle is
going to be H comma K and then the
radius this is the radius squared but
the radius R is going to be our radius
value now one thing to keep in mind when
you're working with this formula say for
example if we had
the standard form of the equation of a
circle and it looked like this
what's the center of the circle well
it's going to be at positive 1
and negative 3. now you might be saying
Mario why is that well you can see
here's X right here's minus and here's H
which you can see is just one whereas
over here this is really like y minus
negative 3. so we're trying to put it in
the same form where you're subtracting
and so you can see y minus negative 3 is
the same as y plus 3. so just remember
it's going to really have like the
opposite sign minus 1 the center is at
positive one positive 3 the center is
going to be here at negative 3 and then
the radius this is 16 we'll have to take
the square root so our radius is just
going to be equal to 4.
and then you can graph it from there
let's dive into a couple examples okay
for number one we're given a center of
two negative 1 and a point on our Circle
five comma three how do we write that
standard form
well remember our Center this is the
point H comma K and remember the point
on the circle we call that X comma Y and
so now what we can do is we can start
off by substituting in our H and our K
so we could say x minus the x coordinate
of the center of the circle
plus y minus the y coordinate of the
center of the circle
and that's our that's our standard form
now the only thing that we're missing
here is the radius squared and what you
can do now is you can substitute in your
X values I'm going to put 5 in for x
and our y value I'm going to put 3 in
for y and then we can solve for this
radius squared now keep in mind when you
subtract subtraction is like adding the
opposite so this becomes like y plus 1
the quantity squared so if we simplify
now 5 minus 2 putting 5 in for x 5 minus
2 is 3 squared and 3 plus 1 that's going
to be 4 squared equals our radius
squared so we have 3 squared is 9 4
squared is 16 and 9 plus 16 is 25.
you can take the square root of both
sides to find the radius that would be 5
but in this case we just need our radius
squared in our standard form so let's
leave it as r squared equals 25. so
we're going to put this back in here for
r squared and that's going to be our
standard form so let's go ahead and
write it out we've got x minus 2 the
quantity squared
plus y plus 1 the quantity squared
equals our radius squared which is 25
and you got it so for number two see if
you can pause the video and try this one
on your own you've got your Center and a
point on the circle how do you write the
standard form of the equation of that
Circle
well if I was going to do it I would do
it the same way I'd notice that my
Center Point is our H comma K and our
point on our Circle X comma y let's
substitute all those values in so we've
got x minus negative 4. I usually do it
in steps I put the H and the K first
and then y minus negative 3
and that's equal to our radius squared
of course when you subtract it's like
adding the opposite so these become the
opposite sign
and now what I would do is put the 4 in
for x and the 3 and for y and we can
solve for r squared so this is going to
be 8 squared
plus 6 squared
equals r squared so we have H squared is
eight times eight sixty-four six squared
is 6 times 6 which is 36 that adds up to
100 and if we take the square root the
radius is 10 but we really just need the
radius squared here so let's leave it as
a hundred and if we put that back in
right here for r squared we've got our
standard form
of the equation of our Circle
and you got it so the next thing that
students are usually asked is how do you
find the standard form of the equation
of a circle when you're given two
endpoints on the diameter of a circle
and that's what I talk about in that
video right there so follow me over to
that video we'll get some more practice
with circles and I'll see you there